Professional developers,
more often than not,
will find themselves working on
pre-existing code with other developers.
They use Git to track changes,
compare versions, and
view the commit history for complex
projects, just like you've been doing.
There's one difference, though.
All your repositories and
changes had been made locally, which
means they only exist on your computer.
And you are the only
one who can see them.
Unless, if all those developers want
to take turns working on your computer,
there needs to be another way for
developers to work on
repositories remotely.
And there is.
In this lesson, you'll learn how
to use Git and GitHub, to view and
update shared repositories.
You'll also practice with
a demo repository and
be able to apply your skills
to your future projects.